situations when it's best to lie travel
edition the creepy person asking is it
your first time visiting
no i used to live here are you staying
at this hotel
no i'm waiting for a friend where are
you staying marriott
because those hotels are everywhere
placing an order for delivery and they
ask for your name the name
oh it's for john a salesman asks if your
parents are home
just leave it at the door thanks you
need to set up a voicemail
hey dad can you record a voicemail for
me on a plane and a chatty neighbor says
i hate traveling alone how about you
same my friends are a few rows back
checking into a hotel alone lying yeah
i'm on my way up
and if a helpful stranger offers you a
ride at the airport no
plus it's illegal in many states hey
when do you usually work
i don't know my manager's always
changing the schedule is this your car
it's borrowed can i get your handle i
have a boyfriend
someone's hitting on you asking where
you're headed next the hospital
someone standing too close you're
uncomfy act a little wacky
and you could always pretend to not
speak the language
when someone asks where you live by the
walmart there's probably a walmart
somewhere where do you work the electric
company where do you go to school oh
it's online
when someone asks if you're alone do you
live alone no you have roommates
traveling alone nope you're waiting for
a friend headed home alone after a night
out
nope going to a friend's house you're
never alone you're just surrounded by so
many people
all the time all the time a repairman
asks if anyone else lives with you
yes and you're expecting people you can
also ask for an id and call the company
to confirm identity
a cab driver asks if you're meeting
friends most definitely
traveling alone and someone asks if you
know people in town or need a ride
you're staying with family and they're
picking you up you're in a cab and the
driver asks
do you live in the building just
visiting my dad do you live alone
nope my roommate he's military driver
tells you you're hot
hi dad can you open the door i'm five
minutes away and shout out to the
drivers that look out for their
passengers working alone and someone
asked oh are you alone
no my boss is in the back live alone and
don't want people to know hey babe
i'm home and when ordering a cab use a
nearby address versus your house if you
don't want them to know where you live
travel safety tips don't keep your cash
all in one place and yes
you should carry cash but split it up in
case of emergency you can hide it in
everyday items like chapstick a mirror
deodorant
even a scrunchie this one looks cute but
check it out
safety tips for public transport i hide
nice looking jewelry even if it's fake
like turning my ring inward or taking it
off put away my work or school id
and i use bags with zippers instead of
open totes
parking lot safety tip if you're getting
out of work or a store
late into an empty parking lot and you
feel uncomfortable here's a hack
use your car alarm as a personal alarm
set it off and if someone's hanging
around
it might scare them off and don't be
afraid to ask for an escort when
possible
to do when you're getting in a cab if
it's an app service check the license
plate name and destination but with any
car you can also check if the child lock
is engaged to check from the outside
look on the side of the door when you
open it if you're inside the car
try opening and closing the door if you
can't open it you know it's engaged
tell safety tips part one lock your door
and use the deadbolt
you can cover the peephole with tissue
paper hang the do not disturb sign and
leave that for the remainder of your
stay
unless you want the room clean and keep
the tv on with low volume even if you're
not in the room
you're at a hotel or anywhere and don't
trust the lots here are four tips you
can bring your own portable lock
or put things behind the door that'll
wake you up like bells
a mug or water bottle on the handle or
floor or an ironing board
you